[Music]
not
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
please
[Music]
hey what's up everyone happy friday
thank you for joining us on this
session of the future academy live
stream today we have a very special
guest
we're talking to james ramirez who is a
motion designer a friend of mine
and who is the co-director of the
spider-verse
main title sequence at the end and i'm
super stoked about this because
one that was a dope movie and two that
was a dope
title sequence and so i've always wanted
to know
what did it take for that thing to be
made what was the process behind it and
how did they get that
very cool mixed media look that i think
really stood out amongst
all of the all of the recent filmmaking
and animation lately so
that's something that's just always
stuck out to me so i'm glad we can bring
james onto the show and uh i want to
welcome all of you who are joining us
live here but if you could help me uh
and welcome
james ramirez to the show yeah
let's go james man thanks so much for
having me on it's awesome to be on
yeah i'm glad we can finally chat about
this and i'm
i i saw some of the behind the scenes
stuff that you've been leaking out over
the
the past couple of uh i guess the past
year and
you know i was like dude we got to have
you on the show this is this is so cool
and i know we're about to
geek out on a bunch of things right now
yeah for sure
i think you're definitely gonna have to
try to uh control me as i
uh meander through everything but
you know it's it's one of those things
where it's like it was such a fun
project but it was also such like a
a crazy big scope so there's like so
much creative things
to talk about and it was such a journey
that i mean it's it's fun to share that
process because you know it's like
my favorite project that i've ever
worked on and i'm really proud of it
and it's amazing when you can spend that
amount of energy and love into something
and then it also turns out good right
and it's client work
because sometimes these things are
sometimes these things are just personal
projects
right but it's it's fantastic when it
lines up with client work and
an ip a piece of property that i'm sure
you adore because i'm a huge fan of
spiderman yeah
yeah it's uh yeah that's that's always
the trick right it's like
finding that balance between uh getting
to feel like you're making art for your
clients and
it is a rare thing i think because you
know a lot of times we're
creative problem solvers so you're just
trying to help them get to that end
thing
and this was a very special kind of
relationship that i think there was a
lot of trust
and i think when you trust in the
process and the team
i think that the overall result of the
film comes from
all the filmmakers at sony trusting all
of their team
and then by extension of that you know
the directors trusting us
to like in their film you know which was
this like really big thing for them so
um it it's a good it's a good thing when
all of those things can align and mix
and nobody feels like you're just like
there's egos or stepping on and it truly
allows for like the creative to bloom
right yeah i think that's actually
something that you could even see in the
final work
i don't know why it just feels like the
final result that we all saw on screen
just felt like it was oozing with
creativity and love and passion
and you could just see that in the film
because it was so fun
and it just i'm glad to hear your
perspective on it because
that definitely shows through and i
think why so many people
have uh enjoyed this film and why it
gained so much popularity when it came
out
yeah i you know i've worked on several
films and every film is very unique and
different you know so they're all
different productions different teams
and they all vary in their creative
process and
nothing it's not like a formula you
can't apply one to another but
this one specifically like every time
we would see like uh an edit update
or kind of dailies from them what the
visual effects team was doing
just everything felt like everyone is
getting to be
imaginative and breaking the mold and
doing different things and i think
everyone had set out on that vision of
doing something different
that no one was being told no like
that's not a good idea or
we're not gonna do that everyone was
like well let's just see what where that
goes
and i think when the film team is uh
allowing that to happen i think you know
i think that's where a lot of that comes
from and so i think the response
it's one of the it's one of the few
films i think that you can actually stop
on any frame especially animated films
you can stop on any frame and it looks
good
yes and that is very hard to do
like even if i go through my work i'm
like oh i want to like take some
screenshots of this piece i did a while
back
right it takes me so long to find like
three frames i like like this one this
one
but this film like you know you could
stop anywhere and it's just like man
there's
it's so well designed that the
environments the lighting the textures
whatever it is
like is just so spot-on and so i think
that's why
it resonates because i think a lot of
times you see
uh film art books look better than the
film
like it's like oh man those illustrators
and all the designers they brought on
were doing these amazing things but it
didn't carry to the final vision
and i think being able to uh
lead the team which you know the
producers and directors were able to do
on this
to get to that final product i think is
i think that's why it resonates so
so well cool well maybe uh for those of
the people in the audience who
might not be familiar with you or your
work i think it might be good
to uh to play your reel so that we could
just
get a sense of some of the work that you
do some of the stuff that you did on
spider-verse
um and then just so we have more context
as we dive deeper into this conversation
so jonah maybe you want to queue that up
yeah and you know for this real
specifically
you know really um take on rails where
she kind of really breaks down you know
she does so much design work
and stuff i thought that was a really
interesting idea and i wanted to embrace
a lot of my creative thinking and
problem solving and what i do
so you know as an art director
usually i'm working on a team as kind of
like a problem solver
and i'm usually trying to help either
come up with techniques or visuals or
designs that can help the team
see things through and so what i wanted
to do is like show that
behind all these pieces in a real
there's a process
and there's iteration and there's design
that didn't make
it and there's a journey there
and so i wanted to try to build a real
around
like that idea and so really is it's
kind of a little bit of a different take
on a reel
besides just beauty stuff but i think it
kind of speaks to
overall my approach to
creative and kind of how i've
gotten to where i have mode i can really
kind of put on a bunch of different hats
i've done design i've done animation
i've done
compositing i've done you know drawing
i've done everything so it's so helpful
to kind of have that bird's eye view to
approach
projects and to be able to kind of slot
in where needed
and so that's kind of like how i try to
present my reel
yeah no i i think that's a gorgeous reel
and um
uh it's people are saying in the chat
it's like super dope bro that's sick
um but yeah i i think um uh nydia diaz
who
we had on the show before uh she has an
amazing reel she's an amazing designer
and she kind of
tinkers too right like she does a lot of
style frames and design but then she'll
do tiny experiments all that lead up to
the bigger
conclusion which is the final piece of
work and sometimes we don't see that but
sometimes that's the most
interesting thing when you can see the
layers that build up
towards something sometimes those are
more fascinating than the actual final
piece so i'm glad
you shared that in your reel yeah i mean
there's there's often
you know like client like we were saying
client work is often
you know it's never just one thing so
sometimes you're just doing
very kind of dry specific things but
you don't necessarily want to share that
or it's not that glorious to share
but still that development i think is is
important and
over the years i i've taken that as like
my main
thing is to constantly be learning
exploring
and kind of you know my curiosity is
kind of what drives me
so i i like sharing that part of it
because that's what
i find that's what keeps me going mm-hmm
man that's rad okay cool um
yeah uh unfortunately some people
weren't able to hear
our uh our conversation during the reel
when we were playing it because i think
the audio took over but that's okay
uh basically the context for the real
was james was
showing uh the final work as well as
process work cut in
throughout and we were referencing uh
designer nidia diaz who was on her show
previously and her approach to real so
we just thought that was a great way to
showcase all of the things that james
does which
he's been in the industry for a long
time now uh
longer than i have and and he's been
problem solving all kinds of different
things and and i think your background
in design and animation
and shooting and compositing and 3d like
all this stuff it all
it all adds up and i think that's why
we're here and why you probably got this
opportunity to work on
something like spider verse where it is
mixed media multifaceted and
probably required a lot of problem
solving yeah
it's uh it's funny because like um you
know when we
when the project came in and then we
were
gonna take it on i like the thought that
popped in my head was like i've been
training like 10 years for this
like because it's just like all these
very like different
things in my life that could have been
very unrelated like
you know i used to do graffiti so it's
like miles did graffiti or you know
like it's like all of these elements
that kind of come back
to my voice and my
i design ideas that i wouldn't have
necessarily
it's not like you could train for those
sort of things to be like oh yeah you
know one day i'm going to need this
knowledge
right the stuff that just you know kind
of comes naturally so
it was a process um
yeah and so yeah i did
i tried to create um some slides to kind
of show
that journey to kind of what that was
like since you're talking about that
like to yeah like
what that was to get there so um because
i i do think that that's like really
important right is
uh like you're saying so
like as a starting point you know when i
was
younger i got infatuated with the web
like i think a lot of people did
and i really got into web design so
again to these things of like i was
doing design-centric things without
understanding what they were or
or how they functioned as things so in
graffiti you're doing typography
colors composition i just wasn't
thinking of it that way
uh you know dancing is like
you know this is something you're very
familiar with you know dancing is such a
specific uh
presentation right you're kind of
putting yourself out there you're
going into the middle of a circle and
you're either putting up or shutting up
you know it's like
right very very there is no like people
who just talk about being very good
it's just like you got on the floor and
it's fun and that's what it is and so
there's all these things in my history
that you know i kind of like got into
web design and was doing flash
and stuff and that took me to
uh i went to the art institute in kansas
city
and i did a bachelor's in fine arts
there and what year was this
2001 2001 all right and
um i basically my degree was in
photography and new media so it was a
very kind of like
vague thing but we were doing um
[Music]
you know i was like covering obviously
photography so
traditional black and white and color
the printing process is
editing but anything kind of computer
related and since i was doing kind of
web design stuff it
it just seemed like that was a place for
me to go
and then when i was in college i kind of
got introduced mk12
who was also based in kansas city and
this these things started clicking in my
head of like oh i've been really
interested in computers
and then i'm really interested in art
but i didn't understand the two could be
combined
so then it was like oh now i can do like
design
and like that's motion and it's like you
know using all of these things that i've
been learning
and so uh i went and interned with them
during my
junior year and
subsequently in 2005 when i graduated
i uh got a full-time position with them
and i worked with them for uh
almost 10 years wow so mk12
you know for those who haven't heard of
them
were kind of early pioneers in the
motion graphics
days and what's amazing about them is
that they were a very
i mean they called themselves an artist
collective and i think that's
very representative of the type of work
that they did so
they were a group of artists who got
together
to make things move
and short films and filmmaking was at
the center of what they wanted to
accomplish
so there's a lot of things that i was
absorbing from them
that you know in hindsight that i'm
really appreciative but i just didn't
understand at the time because i was so
green i was new to this like career but
you know i got to work on
uh several films there we worked on uh
quantum masala stranger than fiction
uh kite runner and we worked on several
like uh
personal uh short films as well history
of america was a really big one that we
did
and so it was this interesting like idea
of
learning all these bits about filmmaking
which wasn't
in my kind of early growing up like none
of there was nobody in my life who was
like introducing me to films or talking
to me about films and so
this idea of like filmmaking
uh that they instilled in me and
also they really embraced experiments
and exploration and so i think there's a
lot of things that
that came out of there for me uh from
that experience with them
and you know that was amazing and then i
ended up moving out to uh to moving out
to rail i ended up moving out to
los angeles in 2014 and i got a
staff position as an art director with
royale
and this was kind of like
a big step in a different direction for
me
in a way because i feel like the
level of work that royale was doing the
quality of it was
you know if mk12 was more kind of like
mograph
and like bashing things together and
more diy
and kind of like cheating things this
was more of like kind of like a
visual effects pipeline where it was
improper compositing and there was like
teams like we had a staff you know there
was like
designers and art directors and and
creative directors and compositors and
and modelers and at emk12 there was like
you know nine of us just doing
everything
and we didn't have titles you know there
wasn't like
i didn't even understand what a title
was you know like they're coming like i
come out here to apply for the job
they're like what was your title and i'm
like
uh they called me delineator which was
this made-up title that i had you know
it's like we kind of had these just
random things attached to us and
i was like i did all these things but
talking to them there
uh i realized i was like that i had all
of this knowledge
that i didn't know other people out here
other freelance artists out here didn't
have
so i had been on shoots i had done green
screen
i had you know done photography i
knew what the entire production workflow
was
from start to finish and i could kind of
like
talk to each part of it even if i wasn't
like an expert at any of it
i still understood the flow of it and
how things progressed
and that gave me such a big
leg up into others that you know were
out here
and so right but it's just something i
didn't realize like i just didn't even
know i was like
i had this knowledge until like you know
like there's a project at the top here
um that was for nike color dry
and i specifically remember like there
was a element shoot that was going to
happen
and nobody was going to go to it
and it was on a saturday and i just kind
of volunteered i wasn't staff yet i was
just freelancing
and i volunteered i said you know i'll
go and
you know look at stuff they're like oh
you you want to go it's on a saturday
are you okay with that and i was like
yeah it's fine
[Music]
and i went and the stuff that i was able
to get
out of the shoot was so much better than
if no one had been there because it was
just
people shooting things that they didn't
they weren't creatives they were just
kind of like
yeah we're gonna shoot some dust and
we're gonna throw some rocks and we're
gonna make some
it was an element shoot but there was no
one going that knew what it was for
yeah so there's things like that where
they were like wow i mean
that was so cool that you did that and
that you had that knowledge to be able
to be
informational and help and so it was
you know things like that um so this
this was a big step in like
learning kind of like going from a very
small studio of doing
diy things to a bigger studio doing
things kind of more proper
um and i was there for three years and
it was
i think you know the friendships and
stuff that i met through there have
stuck with me to this day
like i've still talked to so many people
and then
you know i ended up going kind of
freelance uh after three years
and that was kind of really scary to me
because you know for most of my career
at this point i had been
staff you know like 10 years at um
mk12 and then three at royale and it's
like really short
freelance stints in between so going
freelance out in la was really scary to
me but i ended up kind of having enough
connections and stuff that i landed
at a small shop called alma mater and
it ended up being an amazing experience
for me because
it's a it's a very small shop it's like
three people
it's brian ma the creative director
james anderson who's a visual event
supervisor 3d artist
and ben aptly the producer
and the level of
work that they put out is really
top-notch
and you know brian comes from
working at imaginary forces for almost
10 years and then starting his own shop
and so he this was an amazing step for
me in the sense where
not only did it lead me to spider-verse
but after kind of like freelancing and
working with him for over a year
you know i really looked to him as like
a mentor where i was learning a lot
about my voice
in presenting dex my voice and how
i wouldn't call myself a designer but
he'd be like you design you're a
designer
or i wouldn't call myself uh whatever
and he would always be like yeah
he saw the potential in me more than i
did
or my skills more than i did so i doubt
myself a lot right as
as artists we all do and so it's been an
amazing relationship because
they've been very trusting of me looking
at
the history of my work and
letting me kind of like work with them
in a way that i think is a bit
different than most places who you
freelance for
um and so you know this is like kind of
a smattering of things that
i've worked on just like the neon stuff
is from a rough night title sequence and
there's some mtv
again like not all this stuff is
glamorous like there's some like mtv
kind of
you know show stuff reality tv stuff or
a hoover vacuum commercial
i and it's not that those are
or and this venom wasn't even a project
i won it was just a pitch but i was very
proud
to pitch you know they let me uh pitch
that project on my own
and present in a way of like hey look
we're gonna you know if you want to
pitch on this project we'll just
back you up you can do whatever you want
and so i presented
for what felt like for the first time
out of all my past 13 years where i
pitched on a project and it felt like
my voice i felt like i presented for the
first time as like hey i'm james ramirez
this is what i want this is what i want
to do here's my idea
there's no like extra
frames in here that i don't want to make
there's no treatments in here that i
don't want to do it's one treatment
do you like it we're gonna go for it if
not that's cool i put everything into it
and it felt
great and then immediately following
that you know was kind of like
spider-verse where
you know that landed at the studio
as a as a pitch and it was kind of the
same thing where they
you know brian told me like look we're
gonna pitch on this
um i'm going to do a couple of
treatments
and you can do a treatment and you can
just do whatever you want
and so that's a very
empowering thing right which it took
you know our work relationship of a year
and a half to get to that point
to where like you know he trusted me he
respected me and
i trust and respect them to for us to
get to that point
and so james can i ask you a question
right there
about about the trust because i think i
mean
to have that opportunity is pretty
fantastic right like pretty crazy and
you said
you know it took about a year and a half
of you freelancing there and working on
stuff
do you think there's anything in
particular that built that trust like if
you were to summarize that
uh is does there anything that comes to
mind of like how you build trust because
you've done that in the previous two
shops that you're working at and now
yeah here at alma mater like it seems
like you did the same thing and just
i'm trying to ask on behalf of our
audience like if they want this
opportunity what are some of the things
that they have to do to
earn trust you know
it's there isn't
like it's not like a one two three right
it's not that
um it i don't
know if it's like a repeatable thing
that i could go back and do
but what i did was
um i
showed that i had ambition
to do each step of the process so
when i first started working with like
alma mater
they brought me on as an after effects
animator
and then when they saw they were like oh
you're more than just like an animator
you have more will
let you chip in on some design
and then once they saw like oh you can
do design
then it was kind of like you know kind
of that that's the hardest dance i think
about freelance right is that
you can do a lot and you know what you
can do but when somebody brings you on
new for the first time they don't know
what you can do
so they might be bringing you on because
you know
there's a project that does has type and
you had a bunch of type in your reel so
they're bringing you on but they don't
know necessarily everything else you can
do
so your job as an artist is to
meet their expectations you're like okay
this is i'm gonna do the thing that you
brought me on for but also look
you know you asked me for one version i
did three versions and also
you were using this type but you know
just in case you know you needed some
more i pulled some reference
so it's kind of just going a little bit
extra and over
to show that you're thinking about
things and that you're processing it
and that you kind of have creative input
and now that creative input isn't most
places won't stifle that most places
will welcome it
and understand that a good idea can come
from anywhere but some places you know
you're
very specifically slotting into a
pipeline so
sometimes it's not the best to try to
introduce ideas if
they're in the middle of a project and
you're brought on to do something and
you're like well yeah
a lot of these other things are like
that's great but we weren't we're not
there
so we're not looking for other ideas yet
yeah so
you see you have to you know you have to
read the room and you have to know
where that is initiative is kind of like
is going to get you somewhere and where
that initiative isn't really warranted
um but you know that the trust that i
built
with brian was through
multiple kind of successful projects you
know and
again there was a lot of in-between
stuff that wasn't glamorous but
it was being able to be self-sufficient
and managing things on my own but asking
for help when i needed it
right and i think that's a big thing is
like you know some people are scared to
ask for help and they just want to say
yeah i can do that but
you know actually can't and then
it gets you in trouble because then
you've set yourself up
again with these expectations you set
yourself up for something and then if
you fall short then
it's only you that looks bad so right i
think those
those things are you know important and
you know that's something that i kind of
like also learned through royale that
you know
kind of ended up bugging me a lot that
it was a big life lesson was
you know i we i worked with a lot of
freelancers there you know because there
was a lot of projects and
i remember specifically there was this
nike project that came in and there was
a compositor
who came in and it was me and him on the
job
and a producer came in and said there's
these
changes that the client wants to do and
the guy was like yeah yeah cool yeah i
can do that we
figure it out no problem and then the
producer left and he was like
i don't know how to do that and i was
just like why would you say that now
i have to i know i have to sit here and
figure this out oh gosh
and so he he put me in such an awkward
position of like
needing to research and figure something
out
to meet this expectations of him just
saying
yeah i know how to do this and so you
know that
that was a big lesson to me about when
people
aren't truthful about their capabilities
and i think
what as younger artists again like i
think there's this kind of stigma that
you don't want to ask questions or
you don't want to ask too many questions
but i think more often than not
people are willing to help you if they
have time if you let them know that you
need help
and if you flounder for too long on
doing things that you don't know and
you've all suddenly
wasted three days four days of an
important
project schedule then you've just made
yourself look worse instead of just
initially saying like
hey i know you've asked me to do this
thing but i
i don't necessarily know how to do it
but hey i will look into it and i will
figure it out for you but i just need
if it would normally take one day i'm
gonna need two days or three days
and so i think once you start those
dialogues and you're more honest about
things
i think that's the type of thing that
adds up over time into
a fruitful relationship so i think
there's a there's a lot of things that
um
you know again all of those all of those
things vary because every studio is
different every creative is different
every team is different so you kind of
have to figure out what
works when and where and
you know if you're booked to do a 3d
model
somewhere and then your rail has a bunch
of stuff from other
you know things that you didn't do or
something you know it's like this again
those expectations of like
if they see a bunch of representation of
things that they think you can do and
then you get there and you can't do it
then
we're just gonna sour that relationship
and then also
everything is kind of like a web and
connected web no pun intended
but it's like you know it's like um
every artist talks to each other and
every producer talks to each other and
everyone goes around and
like your name goes around and so uh
these are things that you have to kind
of work on constantly and everyone's at
at different places in their life so you
never have to feel like ashamed of where
you're at like everyone
everyone's been doing this for long like
shorter or longer than you
there's always going to be someone who
knows more than you there's always gonna
be someone who's more experienced than
you
and it's just learning when to kind of
be a sponge
and absorb those things versus like
trying to have
an ego in and think that you can do
something the right way
right okay so let me summarize that and
we can move on to the
next part of the the presentation that
you have so
really to build trust is you just have
to have curiosity and ambition towards
the things that you're working on
on every level right because if you show
that you care about all these steps
then you know people notice that
when you show up over deliver right if
they ask for one thing show three
show that you're critically thinking
about something you're not just doing
the thing that they ask but you're
looking at it from different angles like
what is
what are all the ways that i could solve
this in better ways
and then just be totally honest right if
you can't do something say that you
can't do something and ask for help
but if you could also step in and help
do that right and be helpful where you
can so these are all the things that i
heard
and some things that i notice in
qualities of other uh designers and
artists that are also
that have moved up in the ranks or that
i just find highly valuable and just a
pleasure to work with so
i think these are actually common traits
and and i thank you for sharing your
story on that
yeah thanks for summarizing it so
elegantly
well you say it once and i get to take
the notes and then put it together so
that's why we're here yeah so i mean to
jump
so to jump into like the meat and
potatoes right the fun stuff that we
want to chat about spider-verse so
again um to speak of relationships you
know just to kind of like
set the stage is you know uh alma mater
had previously worked with uh phil and
chris
uh lord miller who did who are the the
producers on this film
they had worked on previous films with
them so the jump street movies
and the lego movie and
simultaneously actually to this
concurrent we were they were doing the
lego movie two
while we were doing this and so it was a
again it goes back to relationships
where it was a trust thing they came
back to alma mater because they had
presented good work in the past and had
done work
good work with them so uh
they came to us and asked us if we
wanted to work on this it was kind of
like a
a pitch or not sort of thing where like
we were the only ones
so we were going to lose to ourselves
you know busy like come up with
something cool or we'll just do it
internally sort of idea
there's more pressure on that when
there's no one else to compete with it's
like it's yours to lose
so but you know it's also like you know
by this point i think maybe a trailer
had been out for the movie
and so i was well aware of it
it looked cool it had been in
development already for a while before
we got
to you know this point
and so that's the stage so then we're
invited to pitch so we pitch
so i made this really bad slide that
i tried to summarize like what this
process was like you know we basically
kind of pitched we
then you know they liked our ideas and
then we sat for a while
you know like you know two or three
months and then
they came back and then we revised our
pitch
we developed the narrative through
storyboards
and you know revised our design
created you know once you have the
design then you start creating animation
so then you have like an animatic and
edit and then
you move towards your final so it's it's
trying to like neatly summarize
everything how it works but really it's
kind of like
there's there's r d and there's motion
happening and then
there's more motion test and you're
going back and forth
and then there's like an edit over here
but then you change that edit and
you're doing look dev and you're
freaking out and
you know the final we also delivered in
stereo is the first stereo project i had
done
oh my gosh so you know it's like there's
this is like the pretty way to dress it
up how you think
it went but really you know it kind of
was like a mess
so this is so like i said our pitch uh
consisted of three directions brian
presented two directions and i presented
uh this one so
you know at this point you know when
we're brought onto the project we
haven't seen the film we've read i think
the script at this point
so we kind of know like the story beats
and we know a little bit about what's
going on
there's multiple spider people there's a
multiverse
and we're looking at exploring that so
my take away from this which kind of
stuck through the end was
well i i should say that their overall
kind of creative brief was to us like
uh is always like the make something
cool but it was in a sense of
our film is gonna be really cool and
stylized what our mission is
is to show a deconstructed comic book
so what is your take on that
how can you show a deconstructed comic
book so
there's a lot to unpack there right
there's
um the nature of an analog
product where you have uh halftones and
screen printing overlaying colors um
reduced color palette uh typography
onomatopoeias
uh you're presenting uh
heroic figures poses or whatever so
my you know my instinct is to go to
immediately to the source so i dove into
all of the miles morales uh comic books
that were out there
i just kind of like got a marvel
subscription on the ipad
and these days it's amazing that you can
just kind of like you know
do that and flick through all of these
this collection of comics that i didn't
have
and not only to look at the story and to
figure out what you know where this film
was coming from but also from a
point of view stylistically like what is
miles world that's already been
established out there
so it's looking at reference and it's
kind of looking at his character but
then it's also trying to start
developing these uh design guides to
move forward on
so like the thing that i i
wanted to convey in my treatment was
reflection
was the thing that i stuck to was well
two things one is
miles is you know this kid who's under
graffiti so i wanted everything to have
a very
tactile um
gritty feel to it so there's a lot of
spray paint
in these and the second thing is that
these are all characters that are
experiencing the same
events but in different worlds or
dimensions
so the idea of reflection of me is like
um
do i have also so the idea that you know
like you could see one character in a
world and in the reflection it would be
the other
another character so the idea was that
you could do this kind of continuous
camera move
and kind of move between their worlds
but they're all kind of experiences the
same dudes like the walk in my shoes
sort of thing
so they all swing they all run they all
land
but maybe they do it in different ways
so that was kind of the thing that i
tried to
convey in my design and so i did
a couple of things directly like the
city was mirrored and
they were flipping and then there was
this kind of panel idea
of trying to introduce panels but you
know comic book panels are very
you know uh kitsch
so you don't want to do it in a bad way
you want to try to elevate it and bring
it into an interesting way so i was
trying to
introduce panels that were uh
interesting
and so this idea of like you know again
like the reflection is by
dividing a single city shot into
multiple colors and you're seeing a
spider person in each different one or
you know a physical reflection
as in the puddle so this was my idea and
treatment
and they liked this and brian's
ideas that he presented were of similar
nature where they were very kind of
graphical
reduced palette uh very flat nature so i
think you know what
the filmmakers kind of saw our take
and um were really
liking the idea that we were pushing
towards something different and kind of
more graphic but again
you know they loved this deconstructed
comic book so the half
and on monopias being in space and speed
lines and stuff
um and so you know we move we move
forward
they they liked it we had a we went and
got drinks afterwards in the old days
where you would go and do a presentation
meeting in person
right we looked at the deck in a room
presented it and i was
freaking out and and also this film
it was basically kind of like there was
like three directors and then phil and
chris
so it's kind of like you're presenting
to like a big roster of people
and they're all like you know well
established you know it's like
uh people that you're presenting to it's
you know uh bob persichetti
uh rut and peter ramsey
and um justin thompson was the
art art director on the film and so it's
like all these kind of like big people
have like their own
like backgrounds and stuff so it's scary
but they responded well
we went and got drinks afterwards and
then we chilled for a while and then
we kind of came back eventually and as
they were developing their film
further and you know by this time then
we watched the film so now we've kind of
digested the world that they've created
and in the state that we watch the film
it's
um i would say that so like my favorite
thing about this project period
is that i got to peek behind the curtain
and watch this film progress
and almost even more than like what we
got to contribute
like that experience for me was like
amazing to see this go from like napkins
sketches
and animatics and previz to
like the final thing and to see how they
were developing things so you're kind of
constantly watching updated edits of
where they're working on things
and to see little character changes that
they would do like hey we added in this
dialogue or this shot so these
characters connect more
or this makes the scene and act 3 more
powerful because
you bond to these characters or this
happens or this color palette and so
i love that idea so that really
changed my life being able to see that
process and i and then i was also
able to be in the room with a lot of
these people so it was amazing
um but so we come back you know uh back
to this idea of like you know we pitched
and then we're gonna revise our design
so they've started developing these
moments in the film
uh which is this screen grab this is not
my artwork this is from the film
um and
they've they call these burst cards so
what would happen is
in the film it would kind of pop for a
frame or two
to these moments and they've started
really
honing in on these this they love these
like in their mind
if they could do their entire film like
this they would but it's so
intense to do these moments because
they're so designed and so
kind of like graphic that they're
they're hard to achieve
and so they basically communicated to us
like look we love your design we love
what you've
you've done but we just want to
integrate some of the things that we
started exploring in these frames
so you know as designers you know i
think
brian had a really good sense of how to
deduce what they were speaking towards
and again it's a limited color palette
it's back to this kind of analog fill of
like you have big half tones and
offsets and speed lines are
a big thing the onomatopeias are very
integrated
and um silhouette is important
so things are getting really reduced
down so even like you know
miles becomes almost like two colors in
this kind of uh train shot
and you know it's just looking at at
those elements and kind of understanding
how to
like pull that back into our design
and so these are i'm going to say these
are like
80 brian and i helped out on some of
these but
i think he was able to really
go back and look at our design and
help approach it through that lens
right so you can kind of see how we've
really integrated the speed lines
they're very much an important part the
automotives are integrated kind of
dynamically uh the
you know spider-man you know hero
spider-man here has been reduced to
black white red almost his blue is
almost completely gone he has no logo on
his chest there's no
web lines on him gwen same thing
so you know it's like taking those ideas
that they were
looking after and revising our set so
now it's like okay great we're
starting to to figure it out here's a
close-up on with that i think
these are rad i i had to say like the
um the collaborative process i think
it's pretty cool to see where your guys
initial
ideas came in based off of the brief and
then you responding to
some of the things that they were
building in house on the film
and then extracting a moment which are
these uh you called them burst
cards which obviously this doesn't work
for sustained moments for a long time
you can't watch two hours of that
because you'll have a seizure but you
know seeing something like this it's
like it makes perfect sense for a main
title sequence on the end
and it looks gorgeous for some reason
it's just like
it all came together even though you
don't see any line work on
spider-man here you could tell his
silhouette because of the distinct uh
parts of his
suit and armor and then just like how
the the lines and the typography
are layered in to still give you that
sense of depth
while everything is still flat there's
no shading which is crazy to me
but it's so dynamic so amazing results
here
yeah so you know the thing that he was
able to retain that
we were able to figure out is also you
know this this
grit texture that's over the type and
him
is still from spray paint so it's still
a spray paint
inspired element that is in there but
now it's just
become a part of the design and it's
also like
roughening all of the edges i thought he
was crazy for this he would take like
our
like renders of the characters or
whatever and then just like run like
roughing edges on it or something you
know what i mean
or dude like dissolve or something and i
was like you're a crazy madman
but it gives this uh idea of
imperfection
which goes back to the comic book analog
idea right
so um and this is another frame that i
did and
again to like you know i think the other
thing that i think is
funny about this sequence again from my
point of view is that
i see this as the most basic thing that
you could ever create
in cinema like it's flat shading it's
standard shading there's no
specular highlights or anything there's
um
there's nothing fancy it's no fancy
renderer it's no it's just very basic
rendering
and you know like at this point you know
they had sent us a spider-man
character but i don't really know how to
rig or do
anything so i like bent him really bad
and you can see he's like
deforming on his elbows really poorly
and you know i'm sitting in a meeting
showing this to
like team at sony who's working on this
film and it's amazing and
you've just taken their character and
you've done this like really bad like uh
stuff on it but again it communicated
what we needed to it
communicated like hey we're gonna make a
bright world they're reduced in
colors and things fall to halftone and
so you know the halftone was
another big point about this so if you
see like even like these speed lines
falling to half tone
but the thing that is tricky about doing
half tones
is that halftones are i don't want to
say easy but
easy to do if you're in a mograph world
where things are flat and you can cheat
and it doesn't really matter our world
was being done
in cinema and it needed to be in stereo
so the interesting thing about halftones
and stereo is stereo is just kind of
like
you're offsetting your images uh left
and right
to create the depth so the further
things are away from the camera
they get further apart and the close you
know the closer they are to
the camera they're more in focus well
when you take something like a half tone
and you offset it and a half tone is a
uniform pattern
so it could just eventually line up with
itself so what it ends up doing is
creating a flat
an unintentional flat of your design so
you're taking something put into stereo
and then it just flattens back out
in a way that breaks your brain and
hurts your eyes and makes you want to
vomit
so i say this from experience of
constantly checking on a 3d tv and being
like
the response we always you could tell
when someone is looking at something bad
on monday you just hear like
you're like it's like response to like
nope that's not right
so that halftone even though it seems
like such an
easy element of it it took so like i
feel like during the entire process
that's one of the things that we
researched the most right halftones
because you have to do it in a way to
where it works in in stereo and in 3d
so there there's a lot that we did to
think about that but i i point that out
because like you know these
um speed lines breaking up if you just
take a half tone texture like you can
see like this back one
where i just did what anyone would
probably do is you matt out
a half tone by a silhouette and what you
get though
is half cut dots and that isn't really
what a half tone would do right it would
fake right there if you're looking at
the details like that's not how a real
halftone would look and most people
won't see that
but if you're if you're really anal
about it or if you're the one studying
it's like
i know what it's supposed to look like
so imperfections matter
and how things cut off matter and i
think those are
the details make the difference i always
say that it's the difference between
good and great and the people that
ignore these details are the ones that
are making mediocre work
i think well so everyone who thinks i
mean i'm
i'm a halftone snob now so anytime i see
it i'm like i'm like that's not right
but you know like these these speed
lines to get it to do this was a
you know it's an involved process to
figure it out you know it's not just a
straightforward thing
so even you know a lot of these designs
so like even in this frame you know
um his hand over here basically falls to
halftones and and it's true to nature
and some of these are kind of just
masked in so
it was it was a mixture you know you
kind of have to do a balance we're
trying to do this in a
finite amount of time with a finite
amount of resources so you're trying to
accomplish what you can
and do it uh the best you can so this is
one where i do
i have this in photoshop i'll just try
to oh also
i had some of these other ones in
photoshop too but um let's go to that
one
i don't know where that one is oh
so so here's a different color of that
same frame right
but looking at you know just this hand
um if i like solo down
like you can see that the actual
silhouette is treated in a way to where
the halftones do it true to nature
of like the size changes instead of it
just being masked
so it's kind of like going through the
design and
figuring out these things of how to
layer and how to
how to address the things that we're
going to end up facing and compositing
in vinyls
so a lot of the design was interesting
because we were we were figuring out a
formula to move forward with
on our finals so it was like learning
how we were going to process the colors
where
texture was going to go how the edges
get treated how
um the letters are treated the
background all of that
so that you know that design process is
important because it's figuring out what
it's going to look like but it's also
helping inform the rest of the
production as well
for sure i just want to take a moment to
acknowledge
some of our audience here dr phelps he
was looking at your photoshop files like
damn the layers
and then you know uh earlier uh let's
see
people were saying uh hashtag real ones
i think hearing your story like a lot of
people are resonating with that and they
understand you know like uh
some other a lot of the things you
shared early on in your career about
your insecurities but also just being
honest and truthful about
what you represent and then and how you
carry yourself in the industry so i just
wanted to acknowledge our audience who
is tuning in live and
and uh as we're getting into the these
juicier moments of
yeah so uh so yeah so this journey
basically you know like
kind of i think the two important things
to figure out
for our production was how does it look
and how does it animate
so we've done pretty good on the front
of like how does it look
we've done a ton of research we've
gotten there and then
we get to this point of like how does it
animate
uh and even kind of like in my original
frames i had always envisioned that so
first thing
about being honest you know right is
like in all of our original meetings
we knew our limited resources that we
would have and we said
um all right i said for sure you know
what
we're doing we're not doing is animating
characters i was like i'm not animating
spider-man i was like there's just
no way that we could get that right like
for how many different characters there
are and
how they move and all of that i was like
we're not doing that i was like so the
idea of like
uh frozen moments will be very important
to the sequence
and extrapolating motion and again this
idea of you know
like a deconstructed comic book but also
the idea of paying homage to traditional
animation
so thinking of like uh frame by frame
animation
and thinking of kind of like early
devices like the zootrope
or this in the middle here is like
muybridge's
uh early photography studies of motion
you know taking heist uh a lot of
sequence
frames to break down the actual emotion
of a horse and you think you know this
was a test to actually
if they could learn if the feet all
leave the ground
at one point in time so you kind of see
that in the second frame
um but then also looking back to the
comic books you know in the comic books
comic books you know i've had explained
to me before like they're a very
non-linear experience and you can
experience a page in any order
you want so you could go to the last
panel you could go to the first panel
and you could go
however your eye is going to take you
but there's also a linear experience
too right but what's interesting about
that is like you have moments like this
to where
miles is swinging in the city but you
know to help
that story go along they've shown him
multiple times in a single frame
or here too like where he's jump uh a
peter's jumping and they
you kind of see a broken out uh sequence
of him
so with the idea of me saying that we're
not gonna animate we're gonna do frozen
moments
what that meant was initially telling
sony like look
for this we're going to need your help
we're going to need to be collaborative
and we're going to need to get
animated assets from you that we'll then
bring into our sequence
so that was kind of you know
we said that out front so that was good
to have that out of the way and everyone
was on the same page
and they really came through
so i think that's an important you know
distinction to make in the sequences
that we
were using their elements from the film
and dissecting it and bringing it into
our sequence and kind of adapting it as
needed
so there's probably like a 50 50 mix of
where 50
is coming from the film straight up like
scenes
shots from the film and then there's
another mixture of like where we needed
custom specific uh poses and things
that were related to our sequence so
this is kind of like an extrapolation of
that idea so here i have a scene
um this is this is kind of like what i
would get from them
which is um miles running
and if you you know again if you're
familiar with the film you've seen
uh there's these sec sections in the
film that are
saying like uh you know like telling
their backstory and they cut to their
backstory so this is where
like this would come from and um
which one are we looking at oh yeah
i'm gonna see the pdf right now is
cinema not
oh yeah i think you have to go to a
share screen and then uh
change the program or just share the
whole desktop
there you go there we go now we see it
oh cinema was trying to not
share with you guys it's not my fault uh
so this is like a small miles here but
from the camera
uh from the film of like you know miles
is running so this is what we would get
from them
so it's a it's an olympic file and it
has all of the animation
so then what i would do is
break this down into frames so i would
like you know
let's say uh let's see here if i can
just
i would i would collapse him down so i
would like go like okay that's a good
frame i'd go
twos or fours and i would duplicate it
and i would uh
collapse him down and then move forward
a little bit
and then do it again you know and say
like okay i like that
shot and i'll collapse them down and
basically you kind of
end up building out of a sequence of
frames that
are the animation wow and so
uh what what then i would do is like
okay you know now we have this like
sequence
of a character moving and we can kind of
put him in our scene as necessary as we
need
um and kind of
develop that for our shots so and
again to this being very basic stuff i i
kind of thought of like the most basic
way to do this was like oh
so i've saved out each of these poses
and i'll just drop those into a cloner
and the cloner will just duplicate them
for infinity like however many i want
right
and then to go back to the idea of a you
know zoho trope is like you know
if you start animating the camera along
this
and you're moving fast enough right you
get into the idea of
a zoetrope so
okay that's it and naturally if you
wanted to film this you would
you know have like a a black frame
insert or something so
a flash so that your eye can kind of see
constant motion
but you know we're we're just trying to
we're treating like the
the frame rate and the
kind of speed as as our arc guide for
this
so so that you know the the motion test
that i
showed to them in the state is a
character that we've taken
into mixamo to do just a jump so he
looks really janky
but right i've taken a cloner i've
replicated him
and i've treated it in different colors
which looks pretty ghetto and it's not
that interesting right but
um what it does is illustrates uh
conceptually
we're gonna see different characters
it's gonna be in different worlds and
this is the style of animation that
we're thinking of
and this was enough to sell them on the
idea like they they thought this worked
really well
and um so that you know this is in the
process of figuring out how this stuff
moves and
and then the second thing that we showed
uh was this test
so this is from uh an artist uh thomas
mcmahon
and he developed this test and it worked
really well and what it is is it's a
visual trick
it's a mixture of
single animations broken out like i was
saying kind of in space but it's also
cloners to create reflections and then
there's also
actual reflections and so it's like a
there's a
if you imagine all this black space is a
mirrored uh surface that we're
not able really to see oh my gosh so
so what ends up being created is kind of
like this you know
uh very interesting fragmented
uh experience of these characters
and this goes back to you know my
exploration again of my reflection thing
kind of stuck through so we're dealing
with reflections
the the multiverse and the film was
represented through
uh kind of like a spider web so we've
also been able to touch on that
right just randomly we didn't plan it it
just kind of happened that way it just
hits all the things yeah
and then what we realized is that if you
added uh strokes or lines to the
um edges of this
of this surface that then also you
create
spider webs right oh so that's so
cool so it's kind of like all these
things kind of coming together to make
the hole so our idea becomes like
okay uh we've we've figured out
um figured out how it looks this is kind
of our devices for our moves our
characters are
duplicated in space and they're in shots
and then we're playing with reflections
and that idea of the multiverse
um dude that's so sick
my brain is a my brain is breaking a lot
of people in the chat are just like oh
this is so interesting
j black says genjitsu okay okay
from uh naruto if you ever watch that's
pretty hilarious
keep going this is so sick so you know
again like you know it's thinking of
things as
you know physical zootropes and taking
these poses and
creating uh kaleidoscopic like effects
out of it um again you know like that
was the other rub with our designs is
you know
i was trying my hardest to avoid
kaleidoscopes i was like kaleidoscopes
are a very hard thing to design and
they've been
done so many times like you to do a
fresh take on them is
is quite hard so let's stay away from
them and then we did our whole
second half of the sequence in
kaleidoscopes so that's how that goes
um
so i think uh so i mean these are just
kind of quick times of
of the thing i was showing so i don't
think they're that
interesting i don't know you don't
discuss that man like those are all
pretty cool like all of these
little motion tests like we were saying
when we saw in your reel
sometimes the process is more
interesting than the
the final result because the final
result we see it and we're like oh
that's rad
and then we stop thinking about it but
once you start peeling back the layers
and say oh well we did this because of
this and then this was an accident but
then this is
what it led us to once you start seeing
the creative thought process that went
behind it and then the trials and
tribulations that got you to those
things
you realize how much thinking went into
it how much effort went into it and then
how creative the final result actually
is so you get this new appreciation for
it so
don't discount any of this stuff if you
have tons of it just keep playing this
yeah please audience is eating it up
so so you know this is like an early uh
exploration from one of the shots that
we were doing in the film
and you know
again this is the idea of like you know
kind of taking thomas's initial motion
test and exploring it a bit further
where
we're transitioning from one character
and the idea was
that we would um
if i did one kind of treating it like
a uh sorry i didn't mean to click off
there if we treat it like a
uh action match cut to where if all the
characters in the camera move is doing
the same between all the characters we
can cut between them and they would
match
so it was kind of starting to explore
that with one character but
exploring the multiverse of the lines
and exploring
the the character treatment and so
you know it's kind of like all of these
so these are all things that are kind of
simultaneously happening you know in my
my earlier graph of like how the the
things are trying to get figured out
um and then i think i had is there
another
oh so this was just um again seen so
like
taking their character let me see if i
can make this bigger
taking their character sequence uh
breaking it into frames
and then also taking their camera move
from the film
so this is you know jumping off of the
building that we see a lot throughout
the film
and exploring that in space so this is
what it looks like so you also run into
like you know wanting to do shots like
this you're going to run into a lot of
issues of stereo where
you can't have objects as close to
camera you have a character going
through camera so you're trying to
figure out you know it's all these like
things that are the development process
is answering a lot of questions as
you're figuring out things
but it became interesting to see these
echoes as like you know
as a extrapolating of this data and
motion and bringing it out
so it's so cool um there's that
and let's see what is next to my
presentation
oh so yeah i mean it's just kind of more
looking at that kind of process that's
what that motion was this is what that
same
clip looks like from the side so i mean
just a segway stop for a second here on
the amazing
team at sony me not again me not being a
character artist and
learning a lot of things the hard way
when you i was very naive and i said
yeah just give me you know the character
from this shot and i'll put them in my
shot
and what i didn't understand is that a
lot of these
probably like i'm going to say like 90
of these shots are
bespoke to the camera so
everything is cheated and exaggerated
to camera so like what that means is i
wish i had a specific example
of this um so like
like you know one one example that i
ended up running into is i asked for
a sequence of gwen swinging and
i i brought it in and it was meant to be
seen from like a three-quarters
of a wide camera but when you rotate it
around what you saw was that her hand
was going straight through her head
so it's these things of like they were
like you know exaggerating proportions
again it's a comic book comic books
aren't just like characters animated
they're like everything is like
foreshortened and
cheated so these character rigs that
they had
were doing all of this without you
knowing it
so it looks right at camera but if you
were to rotate
any degree then it breaks so the naive
james is like hey we'll just get all
these characters we'll put them in these
shots and it'll all work out
and then like they're like yeah you know
you can't do that and it's like
oh and they're also so by the way noir
is animated in a way that
only his whole like cape and everything
is hand animated so like if it
if the cape let's say like the framing
is like this and
you're seeing his midsection they're
like everything below is just static
so like if you were to zoom out his cape
just
it doesn't work you know or right ham is
is hand animated per frame regardless
because he's like a cartoony character
penny is hand-drawn
and like you know it was a custom 2d rig
and you know so there was like
characters like
miles and you know peter burrito is what
they called him the
the main heavy one yeah i called him
pita burrito
and um you know those characters are
kind of more traditional so they're
they kind of had rigs that sort of
worked
you could manipulate them and they
worked in space but again everything is
being cheated to camera so
and in this in this kind of
collaborative
working relationship with them i mean we
were so thankful that they were so open
to sharing their files with us and their
cameras with us so we could use their
cameras where it worked
um so this is kind of like i included
this because this is like
again part of this process of a lot of
things going on behind the scenes you
know
while i'm you know kind of co-directing
this with brian it's like i'm also
managing all of the assets that are
coming in from the client you know i
think we probably had
i felt like a kid in a candy store i
think we had like i don't know 700 gigs
of data from them that needed to be
parsed
needed to be logged needed to be
categorized needed to be
accessible to artists you know it needed
everyone needed a quick way of being
like
i need a miles doing this and i need to
be able to grab that and also know
where it's already being used or where
it hasn't been used or what isn't being
used
so we would get you know she i would
kind of create these sheets
of data like this to where we're able to
see what a shot is
and and what it looks like and what
information is available into that
and also we're talking about working
with like
sony and so sony's all in their own
pipeline and their own
software you know whether they're maya
or whatever like them
sending us stuff and it happening
to work in cinema is like luck you know
like it just
hap like honestly like i want to go back
to the scene real quick where i was
showing the
um so like in showing this
um in the scene from them if you can see
like my
uh object manager over here you know
their characters would come in
with like subdivision objects and all
these different pieces and stuff but
luckily i kind of worked it out with
them
somehow when they were exporting
olympics for us that it came in with
selection tags which was amazing
that it did that because that's how we
ended up texturing the characters so we
would
um if i have another sequence i think
it's that so
you know basically we would create a uh
you know based off of their original
textures that they made for the
characters they kind of treated each
character's body part as a separate map
it's a really smart way of creating
really high fidelity maps for one
character by breaking them into
a ton of like you dims essentially but
we were able to like you know take
advantage of that by just like having
selection tag so then i could isolate
down
shaders and and we could create so what
was nice is i could create shaders that
worked for a character and we could
apply it to any character that came into
us so i could just grab it
and apply it to another character so it
was nice that it was able to kind of
have that flow but it i mean it took a
while to figure that out and
like i said a luck that olympics were
coming in with these tags otherwise
i don't know what we would have done it
would have been a really nightmare to
try to like
rebuild all of this stuff right um
this might be over the head of some
people but it's just like basically
we're
trying to translate between different
programs and sometimes things don't
translate
luckily this carried over and he had the
texture
information that was consistent because
of their pipeline and he was able to use
it across the board in in
in their final process a lot of luck and
then just figuring out the the lego
pieces that you have to play with to put
it together
yeah so here's um so i i have two scenes
here that i just kind of wanted to
dissect that i think are fun to kind of
look at so this one is
um the end very in shot of us flying
through a tunnel
and finding miles so we basically start
the sequence with miles and in the
sequence with miles
is kind of what we end up doing um
and then we cut to the logo after this
and so this was i have a scene for this
that
i think i'll open up and we can look at
and then
the other shot that i have is
is this shot so this is like the first
open this is the first opening shot
again with um this is the start of the
sequence so this is
that taking that run sequence and uh
extrapolating it into like the
zodotropic moment
this is like the speed lines that we're
seeing
and this is kind of like what the comped
version looked like so lorenzo reyes
was the compositor on this project and
again that
royale relationship you know luckily i
had crossed paths with renzo and
he had just gone freelance like right
before this project was gonna start
i immediately stole him and he is a huge
like comic book
uh spider-man fan so it all kind of
worked out
he's in the chat right now he's earlier
he said to name your lairs bro
little josh did you imagine it was it
was
so that was funny as like you know uh
alma mater had never worked with lorenzo
quick renzo story oh my god i've never
worked with lorenzo so they're trusting
me there i'm like hey look we're gonna
bring all rinzo he's the guy
to do this i know for a fact it's gonna
be amazing and they're like well i mean
uh you know we've never worked with him
i don't know and i was like just trust
me
bring him on lorenzo's there starting
for like you know
and he's working on stuff and he's just
so sassy to me he's being so
like you know he's being funny he's
being intentionally funny just back
talking and be like no or like i don't
know whatever renzo does
and then like brian's like man i
i thought he just like i don't know i
couldn't tell if he was being serious or
not i didn't know and i was just like
now we're fine we understand each other
but we had again back to this trust
relationship right where we built a
second hand
like we could talk to each other without
talking to each other so
right i trusted that he could
carry these shots excuse me carry these
shots to where they needed to be
and some of these have design frames
like you've seen you know like we looked
at some of them had design frames and
they're things that you can look at
and you know like there's a lot that we
can pull from the design to build a shot
like this but
something like that the end frames we
didn't have designs frames for
and he built it all somehow and and he
got there
and it was it was one of those things
where we didn't know what it was gonna
look like and then i walked over one day
and saw his updated motion test and i
was like that's it and i just had this
like huge smile on my face and i was
like
we've we've figured it out we figured
out the end of our sequence
um that's so cool but
that's a breakdown of that uh so
this is you know this is kind of what
we'll talk about so this is kind of what
i say when
he figured it out this is a
i kind of did like a time lapse where i
i took well let me let me show this
first let's say so let's look at that
shot that i was just talking about and
that's the opening
so that's what this shot looks like you
know there's like a bunch of environment
there's some cans
there's uh miles running across the
train and
we have it ends in kind of transitioning
to
uh peter peter burrito
and then it uh transitions to the next
shot kind of carries into gwyn
and then each character is kind of
getting like elements from the design
that we're related to each so
uh peter eats pizza when he's being
brought into the portal so there's some
pizza boxes and stuff in the background
and miles with this graffiti
this is a train but it's just set to a
proxy so it looks
all blocky right um but so our
our take again with this like being very
simple the idea was that we would
render a very basic pass out color pass
and then just create a multitude of
layers that we would bring in the comp
to match the aesthetic of the design
so by that i mean that we would take
each character each environment
object and break them out into we use
the take system inside of
cinema 4d which is really amazing
because you can kind of render and it'll
you can set up tokens let's see if this
is set up right
oh yeah so we you know we had tokens and
it'll name it based on the layer and
then name on the take and then we had
you know different you know uh
render presets that you could apply for
each layer so as a way of like
kind of breaking down each shot
into a bunch of layers that we can
composite with and each layer would kind
of get
uh rgb mattes or half tones
or spray paint or uh
speed lines i think there's like a speed
lines pass here
this this is where like you were talking
about my computer earlier we'll see how
much my computer loves me shortly
if we lose james we'll know that uh he
he pushed his computer too hard but this
yeah
so so this scene um you know that's kind
of what this scene is and
i did like i kind of accidentally
stumbled into this uh so i didn't
again uh hindsight i didn't archive all
of these scenes properly so i didn't
collect them all with their assets so i
don't have all the beautiful textures
for these so we're just kind of looking
at the versions that i do have
but this was an earlier version of this
shot where
um so you can see all my pretty rgb on
the
spray cans there um but we kind of
extend it out
this shot doesn't do this anymore but at
one point it went from like
peter burrito to gwen and then from gwen
to
uh noir oh my god which we kind of ended
up changing how that sequence worked out
but it was kind of one long camera move
but you can kind of see
how uh you know that again that kind of
zootropic motion
really kind of was like successful the
other tricky thing one more last tricky
thing for example on the comping stuff
was
was changing again back to the whole
like stereo thing
i'm changing focal lengths here too so
i'm going from like
a do i have maybe it's like a 10
millimeter or something
well so it goes from like a 24 to be
wide
or maybe it's like you know wider and
then it it pushes in to really tight
and then we're like pulling out again to
be wide again so it was like this like
dramatic shift of a camera lens and i
was like afraid that it was going to
make you feel gross but
actually it worked out in stereo it
wasn't bad so i'm going to close it i'm
going to close this scene so that i can
offload some of these so yeah that's
super cool we're doing that i just want
to acknowledge some
people in the chat renzo says thanks man
it was all james kudos to him
i just click on things and stuff and it
happens
[Music]
some people are curious like how long
does something like this take to render
and i have my assumption that it
actually doesn't take that long because
of how you built it
yeah actually i mean that's that's so
again back to this like simplicity thing
right is
because we're just flat shading and
everything is really simple
uh these renders were really fast and we
were rendering
at 2k so it's like 2048 by 858
which is actually we were rendering the
actual letterbox image so
we were saving render time by not
rendering above and below it
um the only thing that honestly was
really heavy render
was the um spider web lines reflections
to get enough like reflection depth on
that so that it looked
nice and the anti-aliasing had to be
pumped up really high because it's
really fine lines
right that was the one thing that we
didn't really anticipate that kind of
ran into
kind of like some render so everything
rendered fast and it was really nice
but the the reflection stuff took
forever
because it's calculating every single
bounce and then you just adjust for
fidelity right how good is
each reflection going to look and that
could get costly
afterwards so so here's the fact here's
a kind of like time lapse that i made of
like speaking of all those render passes
what that looks like
so this is like just turning on every
single one
as they're comped and then
turning them back on as they were
composited
oh my gosh
that's cool can you play that one more
time that's pretty good i think we had a
few drop frames but yeah
yeah so so this is you know this is our
end result right so
again kind of like looking so we had uh
there was like physical balls that we
rendered through the
the reflections this is kind of renzo's
idea to kind of do
like and like throw back to like the
kirby dots from like the comic books you
know
and this is just i don't know
for now lines or spider webs
um our color pass of miles
an outline pass of him
a half tone pass where he's basically
treated with halftones in
kind of like 3d that are being applied
to his
surface so that it moves with him
spray paint texture uh and then the
environment kind of gets all the same
thing where it gets half tones
it gets fresnel it gets different sized
halftones large small
medium there's our crazy like line pass
that looks like um
webbing uh noise
paper texture more half tones
depth pass all of the other ancillary
character
yeah all the ancillary character
reflection and then mattes
because you have to cut out these
characters and this was kind of fun we
created
um the tunnel we broke into uh
rgb colors for each face of the tunnel
we figured out a procedural way to do
this so that we could um
again thinking of each face as a
different dimension for the characters
so that we could bring in
specific characters into specific faces
speed lines
and then it all kind of comes back
together wow that's so cool
and i you know gotta first of all like
that's
that's amazing work but then also i'm
also clapping for renzo because
if he was one of the main comp artists
on this like that's
like 20 layers to play with and then to
make sense of that
he wasn't just the main comp artist he
was like like
he figured this out like you know what i
mean like this he did this
he doesn't want to acknowledge himself
but i will that was amazing so this is
what
this is what his comp looked like um
this is not my comp so i'm not
responsible for this if anything's not
named it's his fault
and so like you know it looks all tidy
and stuff
but you know like again i could kind of
just go we could go through and like
turn off layers and you would just see
like you know the speed lines the half
tones but
really you know kind of the magic was
you know using those
uh rgb passes and an interesting way to
um combine all of these different
elements and textures and layer them to
where
they felt like we were able to achieve a
unique look and again it's all
the kind of stuff that we figured out in
the design phase of
the grit the the lines the roughening of
the
edges the you know reduced color palette
um brian was still so amazed that we
were able to get away with like
rendering
the hero spider-man without his
uh emblem on his chest it's like it's a
crazy thing to kind of take away from
that character is like his main
identifier
right um so yeah so that's what that
looked like and i think
um i mean i i have the scene for that
but
again it's like the same idea where it's
just like you're it's just
moving version of what we looked at
right um
and then the last i think the the last
thing
the last quick time i have here
which again i you know this is something
that you know i'll just need to share
after
but it'll probably have a bunch of drop
frames but this is an interesting
thing that i put together to try to show
that same idea of that journey uh this
is like one of the very first tests that
i did
we were trying to think of webs as a
physical object and if we could render
characters as webs this obviously got
ditched very early on we didn't do this
but
it's just an exploration of that idea
it's a fun
thing that you could bring into
something else but that's uh
expensive to render probably yes it was
very expensive to render
uh but yeah this is this kind of uh
compares i think i'll just kind of maybe
just like scrub through this because
it's easier
with playback but you know like you can
kind of see like the various stages of
like progression from like you know like
our
in sequence ending you know looking like
this at some point and ending like this
you know is is a trusting in the process
you know
wow uh and this was like you know i made
all these like images for the
um well there was a wallet and there are
these awkward family photos
yeah and there are these
they were really funny to get in there
and um
they i mean this is like one of those
things i probably shouldn't say but it's
like they're all based on
like actual awkward family photos we
found
yeah and so we had sony was kind enough
to
endure our joke and matched all those
spiderman poses to all of the photos and
it's amazing
uh but you know this is a great a
breakdown of like you know being able to
go from like you know
storyboard thinking of like seeing
sequential characters to
seeing the animated noir of like him
actually kind of moving as he would
normally but then breaking him down in
our sequence to black and white
um again trying to treat each character
as a specific world and style
uh you can ignore my double up cards uh
but yeah so i mean this is kind of like
was like a
a nice way of like looking at this kind
of breakdown of the process from start
to finish of
like some of these shots and seeing how
they kind of progress to the final
wow and you know like so and
this is probably you know the so there's
our wallet uh this is probably my funny
story too is that
um the entire time they've been working
on the sequence i mean we're getting
like i mean
i swear this is like two weeks out from
delivery
i've been showing we had been showing
the edit the entire time without a logo
at the end it just cut to like a black
box or something right and uh
at one point they were finally like when
are we gonna see the logo and
i was it was just i hadn't thought about
it i was just like
it wasn't on my mind to me it was a
thing that was solved it was like
oh you just cut to a logo it's fine you
don't worry about it
right and then it turned into this huge
like ordeal at the last minute of like
trying to figure out what
this logo was and how it moved and how
it introduced and
you know i thought we were just going to
take their poster art and
you know put it on the end of the film
but they actually it turned out they
didn't like their poster are
like they were not that they didn't like
it they just wanted to do something
unique for the film
so we ended up um
working with our team to kind of create
this more stenciled
paint painted painterly look but it was
really
uh pretty funny to work on a main title
sequence and to forget to work on the
main title
until the very end of the project and
i don't necessarily know how i got away
with that but it all worked out somehow
i i think that's uh in the hands of any
skilled designer or artist uh we make it
work right
that's just that's our job that's our
job
so yeah i mean sorry i know that's like
really long-winded and i feel like
there's a lot of the process that
you know i probably skipped or forgot or
jumped around a lot but i mean it was
such a you know
to me the monumental challenge was
i was being put in a role that i
specifically a
i'm going to say that i went in just
thinking i was going to be art director
uh brian was very kind and at the end of
the film
like we were like i don't know sending
it to south by or something and
he added on the credits as me as
co-director and
i was i was like what i was co-director
and
he's like uh yeah i was like oh cool
but it you know it was this role that i
had never really
um kind of filled before and it it was
um a big task you know there was a lot
of
scheduling there was a lot of figuring
out how to get stuff done in time there
was a lot of
you know revisions and there's i i
learned a lot about
my creative process too i i want to be
a creative where i i walk this line with
my team
to where i don't want to stifle ideas
you know i want ideas to flourish and i
want people to come up with ideas and i
think everyone should be able to offer
ideas and
and that process should be very fluid
and i think there's this balance between
giving a structure
and giving strong direction versus like
forcing people to just
kind of pixel push your direction you
know like you want
people to feel like they can kind of
bring something to it so
i think part of early on in the process
maybe i was a little
too fluid in hindsight where i wasn't
giving a lot of direction but it was
also from
this almost ins you know this insecurity
again about you know me not
feeling like i had the best thing to say
but you know what ended up happening a
lot
honestly was kind of like a big surprise
to me was i would do these kind of
various motion tests like that one of
like in the tunnel with the reflecting
uh spider-man characters i showed you
earlier on with the green screen thing
um there was all these motion tests that
i made that i end up like you know i
would cut out of the conform as i was
building
and then brian would be like where are
those shots you made and i was like oh
they were just testing they were
they weren't like meant for this and
he's like no no just
just just make just put that in there
and just do that that's already done
just do that and so like
there's a lot of convincing of me you
know him to me of just
like having confidence in what i was
making
um but it was amazing from like his
point of view what was i i learned a lot
from him about
you know the overall story he was so uh
instrumental
in making sure that the narrative
carried from point a to b
which i didn't really talk a lot about
the narrative i kind of was diving into
the technical and the developmental
process but you know that the narrative
is
is kind of introducing the characters
their worlds
mingling those characters and then kind
of getting into the multiverse through
the absurdity as um phil would say
uh of of that multiverse since we've
you know you've where this sequence
comes at also
in at the end of this film is you've
just experienced act three which is the
most intense
crazy visual treat ever right like that
act 3 is so intense so
coming out of that into a sequence that
feels like you can kind of catch a
breath
but still kind of have some of that
energy it was a really challenging thing
to do
and you know you're basically cutting a
music video and once you have you know a
music track you're trying to pace it to
that and
and adjust that narrative so there's a
lot of things that we were working on
constantly and honing it in so there was
a lot of moments of
i don't want to say aimlessness but kind
of
exploration and kind of opening it up
and so to some people that can
feel drowning and so i never i never
wanted my team to feel like that i was
leaving them out to just drown i just
wanted to leave room for people to speak
up but also still give enough
strength to it so i brian really helped
shape the overall narrative of the piece
and carry it through and
trusted me to help bring that vision to
life
and so it was a true testament to
everything that i like to do it was
i like to design i like to
explore i like to creative problem solve
and i feel like again you know
for the first time i feel like i had a
piece that was genuinely me
i that made it to a feature film you
know like
i can watch that sequence and i can feel
like my fingerprints are on it and
there's not a lot of work
that outside of my personal stuff that i
feel that way about you know like
i i don't mean this in a completely in a
way to sound negative or mean or
anything but i can look back at my
royale work
and i could say you could remove me from
any of those projects and you would
never know i was on them
right from my point of view right i
understand maybe i was instrumental in
helping something or figure something
out or this or that but
to me you couldn't look at that work and
be like oh james was involved with that
because it's a shiny shoe render and it
you know it's enough
whatever it's photo real and even if
it's just
not technique but it's
taken me you know a long
while to feel confident in what i can do
and understanding that collaboration is
the true
nature of what i enjoy so what i see
these days is a very like simple motto
and it's just that i want to make cool
[ __ ] with cool people like that's it
it's such a simple distillation of
everything that i that i
want to do um because you know like i
said not everything's gonna be glamorous
not everything's gonna be
portfolio worthy and
you know you have to enjoy the process
and enjoy
enjoy what you're making and and then
you know to
the young people too the thing that
takes a while
to learn is you have to separate
yourself from your work as well
and that's a hard thing to do too
because sometimes we get so
personally attached to what we're making
that we think that if what we made fails
that
we have failed and that's not
necessarily true especially in client
work is just
not right for the brand or client or
idea and so
there's this constant battle as an
artist to be proud of what you're doing
and
and be fulfilled by it but also remember
that you can remove yourself and
be fulfilled by all of the things that
added to my character to be able to work
on this the breakdancing the graffiti
the
web design the whatever the video games
all that stuff
feeds into this and so it's all i'm glad
that i do all of those things outside of
work to
feel like you know that that that adds
up to this moment
and to keep growing you know
that's that's rad yeah really um
thank you james for sharing all of that
for your
journey to get to this point and your
honesty of showing
you know i was like maybe you weren't
that confident in your skills and even
up until this last
massive amazing project and you know
sometimes it just takes the right person
to
extract that out of you the right
conversation the right mentor the right
person to just say
no man you're you're amazing and i'm
hoping that
having more conversations like this like
what we're talking about right now just
is is a is a kinder more honest
reflection of
who you are because you're pretty
amazing um and you're just this kind
talented
uh person that i've been fortunate
enough to to know and everybody here in
the stream has been able to
to learn a little bit better so i thank
you for sharing those messages and i'm
sure a lot of people can resonate with
that
um you know i don't know if there's any
uh questions from the audience that
maybe if you guys have anything that you
want to ask james go ahead and drop it
in the chat
um but i think you covered quite a bit
because there was some some questions
early on about your early career but i
think you just kind of
encapsulated a lot of that in your your
your closing there
so if anyone else has a question uh feel
free to
just ask uh before we we let james go
i did see one uh previously early on
that said from it's from flow what
advice would you
give to someone that wants to be a movie
title designer
um i you know that's
often a question i'm asked because i've
happened to work on some title sequences
but
like my story says i never set out to
work on this stuff it just kind of
happened
so i always tell people you know put out
there
the work out there that you want to make
no one's going to hire you for things
that they're not seeing you make
so just build your own personal work of
the things you want to do and
when people see that they'll you know
think of you so that's the easiest way
the other way is you know the more
direct way is like
you know try to work and collaborate
freelance or whatever with the shops
that are working in titles that you like
their work
you know if somebody inspires you that's
doing title design
go hit them up and try to you know get
in with them and that's
going to be your best route you know
yeah i think that's that's the best
advice chris gives it all the time it's
like if you want to
work in a particular industry or studio
uh go look at that studio's work
and then close the gap between your
portfolio and theirs you know it's like
if
if you want to work at a place like
elastic who does high-end 3d stuff
guess what you have to be good at
high-end 3d stuff it's like as simple as
that and then you just show up
um and be persistent and then and then
you'll start working on that stuff so
luckily for you i think you you grew up
and came up in a time where
motion was still kind of finding its
legs and it was very mixed media
early on right and yeah you got your
hand
in many things like live action 2d 3d um
and then bringing in obviously your own
angle and experience and all of that so
that's pretty fantastic to be able to
have all those things and
brought you to where you are yeah uh
yeah i'm i'm very
fortunate to uh have the journey i did
you know i i'm
i try to not plan things out and i try
to just let it kind of the road goes
where it goes and i'm gonna follow along
and try to not get upset when
there's a bump or it doesn't go the way
i plan um
and just try to and you know you just
try to go with it and figure out what
what to do and
i think as long as you're enjoying it
you're gonna find work and so you just
have to make sure to
present the stuff you want to do if you
fill your portfolio site or your
instagram or whatever
with a bunch of one thing guess what
that's what people are going to think
you do
so that's what you're going to do and so
but i also think you know you again back
to this whole like everyone's in
different experiences so
like you know you could want to just do
nike spots and then
you realize after a year of it that
you're tired of shoe spots
and so it's like you learn what you want
to do next and so you kind of learn
through experience of of what is kind of
hitting that itch for you
mm-hmm that's great yeah you could get
tired of something and you could always
change direction that's the beautiful
thing right and
as a creative you get to explore it's
important to go deep
and exhaust the well until you're just
like you know what now what
right now you can add some new skills
you can explore some new things which
i see you're constantly doing there is a
question here from uh
jewel many in the chat this person says
do you ever prefer
do you always prefer designing in 2d
first before you jump into 3d or do you
just sometimes just jump into
cinema right away to flush out an idea
um it's a good question i think there is
not one approach that i take i just take
the approach that whatever gets it done
so um i don't prefer any sort of
software over another i'll
open whatever software it takes or i'll
open whatever
you know gets the idea out so sometimes
it's
sometimes it's i there's there's two
parts there's two parts of this that i
think is my design
design design conundrum that i try to
avoid
one is comes from like working at a
small shop like mk12 is anytime you
design something you needed to
know how to make it so i would always
make sure that i could make it if i was
gonna present it
and sometimes it's limiting though
because you could
eliminate a really good idea just
because you technically don't know how
to do it when you could
hire somebody to step in and help you
with that and say you had a really great
idea that did
water stuff or sims or something you
didn't know how to do that well
instead of just excluding that idea that
you know
in the presentation they could really
like that idea you could just
represent it in a way to where you know
that you can find announce
outsource it and get that accomplished
so
sometimes it is good as
a means of knowing that you can produce
it of making it in cinema or make it
into photoshop whatever works but
sometimes i say just go into photoshop
and don't limit yourself and just don't
worry about
necessarily technically how it's going
to be made but just
make things you know right and i think
that comes with exploration the more you
get to do
exploration like on the nights and
weekends and whenever you just have free
time to just explore either new software
new techniques
those become tools that you can approach
other
problems for in the future and you don't
necessarily need to know it
at an expert level but if you know a
little bit about it
what you can do is you can start to say
ah it could be a little bit of this
it could be a little bit of this and i'm
very knowledged in this thing so if i
take my course skill and then sprinkle
in these other two things and it kind of
looks like it might work right like your
motion test and we do this all the time
in in the motion design industry
then once the pitch is won once somebody
buys the idea
then you just hire the experts in those
two other categories and it's like now
let's do this let me
let's bring the renzo in to make this
actually happen right yeah
no i i that's a very uh great way of
putting it i always think of like you
know
um all of my experiments that i'm doing
at night i do a lot of like personal
exploration of
you know particles or after effects
stuff or i do a lot of vr
and it's not necessarily that i'm
thinking of like these things are
useful towards anything i i love having
this toolbox
for when you come to a problem you'd be
like oh actually you know what a year
ago
i made this project that did just this
thing so if i just take that and tweak
it it'll
work for this and so there's a lot of
that ideas that are just kind of like
you know
um stacks you know they just kind of
like layer up in your building folders
and it all kind of like culminates to uh
great ideas
that's that's it's so fun it's so so fun
okay
there's uh there's one last question
here that i want to uh
ask and before we wrap up and this one's
from
altsumi uh it says hi i've just started
studying graphic design and i'm
interested in motion graphics
just wondering how long did it take you
to go from that beginner stage
to being at a level where people could
actually hire you
interesting um i
i don't i don't i don't know that's
really tricky because i
wasn't when i got into like web design
and flash and stuff i wasn't really
learning with the idea of trying to get
a job i was just doing stuff so there's
a lot of
uh knowledge that i built up before i
was actually trying to
get into the career of getting hired so
i feel like my journey's so weird that
i don't know the actual like how to like
phrase that experience but i feel like
it's just kind of
you know keeping your your head down
into it and learning it
and then what you just want to like
learn the basics so that you can kind of
work in that production environment and
again to this idea of like you know
you're trying to learn towards your goal
of where you're trying to work so you
just want to make sure that you're
learning what those fields require
what your responsibilities would be as
an artist and
and kind of honing in that you know like
if you're trying to learn graph you know
um after effects you don't necessarily
need to
know how to do like character rigging in
after effects you could learn how to do
really great typography you could really
learn how to do
great compositing you know like it's
such a versatile tool that
um i would highly suggest kind of just
picking a couple of things to focus on
and get good at those and then branch
out from there uh because other if you
just try to learn everything at once
you're gonna
overwhelm yourself and then you know
kind of feel like you don't know enough
so
i think that's probably the best
approach yeah i i
agree and you know everybody has uh i
think part of it is
uh ambition and and hard work and then
the other part is just luck right
you were in kansas you went to school
there and mk12
happened to be in your backyard and you
i mean that's not to discount your work
but you were at the right place at the
right
time with the right attitude so i think
all of those things we can't discount
the luck that we all have the the
fortune that we all have but at the same
time it's like some of that
you can definitely manufacture a lot of
it you can just
through sheer will make it happen yeah
for sure
no i mean there was no like i i think of
myself as being in
the right circumstances at the right
time and i know i know it's like
you never want to discount hard work by
saying look but
you know there was a lot of my path that
just kind of found itself and it was
unplanned you know i was from a really
small town in
texas and there was no one in my family
had gone to college before and there was
no reason
for my mom to say yeah you can go to art
school when no one
she it's not like she said what are you
gonna do get a how are you gonna get a
job using that or like you know there
was
none of that it just was like uh okay
and
you're gonna go move there all by
yourself you don't have any family there
okay
and like we don't know how we're
financially going to do that okay and it
was just like
it just kind of went and happened and so
um and i think there's a lot in
my career where i happen to be
surrounded by people like i kind of said
it's about uh brian but it was also like
at mk12 where they saw
the possibilities in
me that i didn't see so so they saw that
i was willing to kind of put in the hard
work and that i could learn
and even though i didn't you know fully
know what i was doing at the time or
have the best sense of it it was
the fact that i had that ambition and
the fact that i was willing to
to do that and put in that work and that
they could see it that
you know that kind of just kept evolving
me and giving me opportunities to grow
yeah cool well thank you so much james
for sharing that
uh you can find more of james at
friedpixels.com and
fried pixels on both twitter and
instagram check out his
instagram because he posts all kinds of
dope experiments there
almost daily like he's posting crazy
stuff that uh
you could see where where his mind
explores and then probably a few months
from now you'll see him working on some
crazy project
that's a result of all those experiments
so follow him there uh he's
he's good people and james thank you so
much for being generous with your time
and your process here and
i know we all learned a lot and i
personally geeked out quite a bit
oh yeah i mean thanks so much for having
me i mean it's a pleasure and
you know uh i don't wanna i never wanna
state
working on that film like it was a
single person thing you know it was like
a team and
it's a big collaboration amongst a lot
of people and so
um yeah i'm i'm very honored to be able
to talk about it and share our
experience and
um yeah thank you for having me cool
jonah can you take us out yes thank you
everyone for tuning in
we will see you on the next episode
[Music]